Hey, guys.
Welcome back.
Today, we're going to do another
fun problem, which is
a drill problem on joint PMFs.
And the goal is that you will
feel more comfortable by the
end of this problem,
manipulating joint PMFs.
And we'll also review some ideas
about independents in
the process.
So just to go over what
I've drawn here, we
are given an xy plane.
And we're told what
the PMF is.
And it's plotted for you here.
What these stars indicate
is simply that
there is a value there.
But we don't know what it is.
It could be anything
between 0 and 1.
And so we're given this
list of questions.
And we're just going
to work through
them linearly together.
So we start off pretty simply.
We want to compute, in part a,
the probability that x takes
on a value of 1.
So for those of you who like
formulas, I'm going to use the
formula, which is usually
referred to as
marginalization.
So the marginal over
x is given by
summing over the joint.
So here we are interested in the
probability that x is 1.
So I'm just going to freeze
the value of 1 here.
And we sum over y.
And in particular,
1, 2, and 3.
So carrying this out, this is
the Pxy of 1, 1, plus Pxy of
1, 2, plus Pxy 1, 3.
And this, of course, reading
from the graph, is 1/12 plus
2/12 plus 1/12, which is
equal to 4/12, or 1/3.
So now you guys know
the formula.
Hopefully you'll remember the
term marginalization.
But I want to point out that
intuitively you can come up
with the answer much faster.
So the probability that x is
equal to 1 is the probability
that this dot happens
or this dot
happens or this dot happens.
Now, these dots, or outcomes,
they're disjoint.
So you can just sum the
probability to get the
probability of one of these
things happening.
So it's the same computation.
And you'll probably get there
a little bit faster.
So we're done with a already,
which is great.
So for part b, conditioning on
x is equal to 1, we want to
sketch the PMF of y.
So if x is equal to
1 we are suddenly
living in this universe.
y can take values of 1, 2,
or 3 with these relative
frequencies.
So let's draw this here.
So this is y.
I said, already, y can take on
a value of 1. y can take on a
value of 2.
Or it can take on
a value of 3.
And we're plotting here, Py
given x, y, conditioned on x
is equal to 1.
OK, so what I mean by preserving
the relative
frequencies is that in
unconditional world this is
dot is twice as likely
to happen as either
this dot or this dot.
And that relative likelihood
remains the same after
conditioning.
And the reason why we have to
change these values is because
they have to sum to 1.
So in other words, we have
to scale them up.
So you can use a formula.
But again, I'm here to show
you faster ways of
thinking about it.
So my little algorithm for
figuring out conditional PMFs
is to take the numerators--
so 1, 2, and 1--
and sum them.
So here that gives us 4.
And then to preserve the
relative frequency, you
actually keep the same
numerators but divide it by
the sum, which you
just computed.
So I'm going fast.
I'll review in a second.
But this is what you will
end up getting.
So to recap, I did 1 plus 2
plus 1, which is 4, to get
these denominators.
And so I skipped a step here.
This is really 2/4, which
is 1/2, obviously.
So you add these
guys to get 4.
And then you keep the
numerators and just
divide them by 4.
So 1/4, 2/4, which
is 1/2 and 1/4.
And that's what we mean
by preserving
the relative frequency.
Except so this thing now sums
to 1, which is what we want.
OK, so we're done with part b.
Part c actually follows almost
immediately from part b.
In part c we're interested in
computing the conditional
expectation of y given
that x is equal to 1.
So we've already done most of
the legwork because we have
the conditional PMF
that we need.
And so expectation, you guys
have calculated a bunch of
these by now.
So I'm just going to
appeal to your
intuition and to symmetry.
Expectation acts like
center of mass.
This is a symmetrical
distribution of mass.
And so the center is
right here at 2.
So this is simply 2.
And if that went too fast,
just convince yourselves.
Use the normal formula
for expectations.
And your answer will
agree with ours.
OK, so d is a really
cool question.
Because you can do
a lot of math.
Or you can think and ask
yourself, at the most
fundamental level, what
is independents?
And if you think that
way you'll come to
the answer very easily.
So essentially, I rephrased this
to truncate it from the
problem statement that
you guys are reading.
But the idea is that
these stars are
unknown probability masses.
And this question is asking can
you figure out a way of
assigning numbers between 0
and 1 to these values such
that you end up with a valid
probability mass function, so
everything sums to 1 and such
that x and y are independent?
So it seems hard a priori.
But let's think about
it a bit.
And in the meantime I'm
going to erase this
so I have more room.
What does it mean for x and
y to be independent?
Well, it means that they don't,
essentially, have
information about each other.
So if I tell you something about
x and if x and y are
independent, your belief about
y shouldn't change.
In other words, if you're a
rational person, x shouldn't
change your belief about y.
So let's look more closely
at this diagram.
Now, the number 0 should
be popping out to you.
Because this essentially means
that the 0.31 can't happen.
Or it happens with
0 probability.
So let's say fix x equal to 3.
If you condition on x is equal
to 3, as I just said, this
outcome can't happen.
So y could only take on
values of 2 or 3.
However, if you condition on x
is equal to 1, y could take on
a value of 1 with probability
1/4 as we computed in the
other problem.
It could take on a value of
2 with probability of 1/2.
Or it could take on a value
of 3 with probability 1/4.
So these are actually very
different cases, right?
Because if you observe
x is equal to 3 y can
only be 2 or 3.
But if you observe x is equal
to 1, y can be 1, 2, or 3.
So actually, x, no matter what
values these stars have on, x
always tells you something
about y.
Therefore, the answer to
this, part d, is no.
So let's put a no with
an exclamation point.
So I like that problem a lot.
And hopefully it clarifies
independents for you guys.
So parts e and f, we're going
to be thinking about
independents again.
To go over what the problem
statement gives you, we
defined this event, b, which
is the event that x is less
than or equal to 2 and y is
less than or equal to 2.
So let's get some colors.
So do bright pink.
So that means we're essentially
living in this world.
There's only those four dots.
And we're also told a very
important piece of information
that conditions on B. x and y
are conditionally independent.
OK, so part e, now that
we have this.
And by the way, these two
assumptions apply to both
parts e and part f.
So in part e, we want to
find out Pxy of 2, 2.
Or in English, what is the
probability that x takes on a
value of 2 and y takes
on a value of 2?
So determine the value
of this star.
And the whole trick here is that
the possible values that
this star could take on are
constrained by the fact that
we need to make sure that x
and y are conditionally
independent given B.
So my claim is that if two
random variables are
independent and you condition
on one of them, say we
condition on x.
If you condition on different
values of x, the relative
frequencies of y should
be the same.
So here, the relative frequency,
condition on x is
equal to 1.
The relative frequencies
of y are 2 to 1.
This outcome is twice as likely
to happen as this one.
If we condition on 2 this
outcome needs to be twice as
likely to happen as
this outcome.
If they weren't, x would tell
you information about y.
Because you would know that the
distribution over 2 and 1
would be different.
OK?
So because the relative
frequencies have to be the
same and 2/12 is 2 times
1/12 this guy must
also be 2 times 2/12.
So that gives us our
answer for part e.
Let me write up here.
Part e, we need Pxy 2, 2
to be equal to 4/12.
And again, the way we got this
is simply we need x and y to
be conditionally independent
given B. And if this were
anything other than 4 the
relative frequency of y is
equal to 2 to 1 would be
different from over here.
So here condition on
x is equal to 1.
The outcome, y is equal to 2
is twice as likely as x is
equal to 1.
Here, if we put a value of 4/12
and you condition on x is
equal to 2, the outcome y is
equal to 2 is still twice as
likely as the outcome
y is equal to 1.
And if you put any other number
there the relative
frequencies would
be different.
So x would be telling you
something about y.
So there would not be
independent condition on B.
OK, that was a mouthful.
But hopefully you guys
have it now.
And lastly, we have part f,
which follows pretty directly
from part e.
So we were still in the
unconditional universe.
In part e, we were figuring out
what's the value of star
in the whole unconditional
universe?
Now, in part f, we want the
value of star in the
conditional universe
where B occurred.
So let's come over here and plot
a new graph so we don't
confuse ourselves.
So we have xy.
x can be 1 or 2.
Y could be 1 or 2.
So we have a plot that looks
something like this.
And so again, same argument
as before.
Let me just fill this in.
From part e, we have
that this is 4/12.
And we're going to use
my algorithm again.
So in the conditional world,
the relative frequencies of
these four dots should
be the same.
But you need to scale them up so
that if you sum over all of
them the probability
sums to 1.
So you have a valid PMF.
So my algorithm from before
was to add up all the
numerators.
So 1 plus 2 plus 4 plus
2 gives you 9.
And then to preserve the
relative frequency you keep
the same numerator.
So here we had a
numerator of 1.
That becomes 1/9.
Here we had a numerator of 2.
This becomes 2/9.
Here we had a numerator of 4.
That becomes 4/9.
Here we had a numerator
of 2, so 2/9.
And indeed, the relative
frequencies are preserved.
And they all sum to 1.
So our answer for part f--
let's box it here--
is that Pxy 2, 2 conditioned
on B is equal to 4/9,
is just that guy.
So we're done.
Hopefully that wasn't
too painful.
And this is a good drill
problem, because we got more
comfortable working with
PMFs, joint PMFs.
We went over marginalization.
We went over conditioning.
We went over into
independents.
And I also gave you this quick
algorithm for figuring out
what conditional PMFs
are if you don't
want to use the formulas.
Namely, you sum all of the
numerators to get a new
denominator and then divide all
the old numerators by the
new denominator you computed.
So I hope that was helpful.
I'll see you next time.